so the way people are portrayed in
drowning in movies is very different
than how people actually draw in real
life for example in movies people tend
to go ah help them drown but experts on
drowning pointed out when you are
drowning you can't speak because you
have water and you're trying to breathe
so there's no sound coming out of your
throat also people who are drowning do
not splash on the surface because they
can't swim they're instead sinking
they're trying to get up to the surface
instead somebody actually made a website
where they've compiled security footage
from various pools not of people
drowning we're not going to watch
anybody die don't worry what we're going
to do is we're going to look at this
pool and you're going to try to spot the
person who's in distress who's starting
to drown before the lifeguard does okay
and at every video the life ride will
jump in and grab the person so you're
going to see if you can spot them before
the lifeguard jumps in let's do this and
there's like a spooky face kind of like
scare us at the end
about two years ago all these really
sweet gimbal systems came out for cinema
cameras
but the thing is
they were limited they were delicate and
there wasn't a ton you could do with
them well things have changed our friend
casey has brought over this acr system
and this bad boy is way more advanced
than the older system so we're gonna
play around with it today we're gonna do
some things like shooting it with 90
degree
angles straight down at the ground
permanent dutch angles and oh also the
panning capabilities when going between
two different subjects
almost instant we're gonna try that out
get some great shots see how it looks
yeah it's pretty stable let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so i said i can't go with you to boston
but that's a very nice ski mask
as you can see this gimbal does it all
you take your significant other out on a
date can pay your mortgage and give your
mom flowers on mother's day i mean
really wow casey thank you very much not
a problem man if people are interested
in finding out more about this what do
they need to do
you can check out acr systems on
instagram or the internet which is 3 500
for the full system without a pelican
case but other than that ready to go
sweet
z
dude wow almost done they're not even
initialized oh god save just save save
save
about the drowning child all right
here we go guys it's about the drowning
child
oh that's an easy one oh yeah wait oh
[ __ ] oh my child wasn't driving this guy
right there right there
right there yep yep yeah that's what i
thought it was too it's goggles boy no
no no he's swimming wasn't goggles boy
right there you missed it oh dude
yeah he's kind of acting like the
movie's there he's kind of like hell
pale
this is really intense having a child of
my own
no no he's just swimming he's swimming
that boy yeah it's that boy
it's that boy
this kid yeah this kid
man who are these kids what is this is
this do they get how do they not only
get that six foot line
don't go in a pool if you can't swim all
right right there
no i'm calling it oh dude you're right i
think it's this this person in the tube
they're about to slip through the ground
they they kind of look like they see how
kind of stupid they look is that person
in the corner no i don't know he's
smooth
man being a lifeguard was here really
dude this is like yeah don't be high and
go to work as a lifeguard i can't tell
if they're just little [ __ ]
or if they're drowning
dude how many people are drowning in
this video oh
everyone's right there
oh yep yep there you go that no yep
they're struggling the person's trying
to get their head above the ground
slapping the surface
yep good work jake oh wow
dude my heart was racing
dude this this pool not a good
reputation where is this let's not bring
our children to this way oh is this kid
gonna visit
oh there he is
spotted him yeah spotted him yep oh come
on man
he's trying oh maybe he's okay actually
no he's totally fine what's that kid
he's better is that kid we got some
splashes i don't know dude that kid's
[Music]
all right i gotta go
i'm glad that we've done our our our
good samaritan deed for the day kids
learn how to swim oh it's this little
nincompoop he's done he's done no he can
swim no he's done look at this see boom
slam it down except in rare
circumstances giant people are
physiologically unable to call it for
help drying people's mouths alternately
sink below and reappear above the
surface drowning people cannot wave for
help
and then from beginning to end of
instinctive drowning response people's
bodies remain upright in the water with
no evidence of a supporting kick so
people aren't kicking their legs and
they're staying up and down and they're
reaching up at the surface
so those are the actual signs of
drowning go to spot the darning channel
dot com if you guys want to practice on
your own to spot the signs of drowning
you have some sick pleasure from that
today
i shoot justin in the face
using only a prop gun visual effects and
the grace of cthulhu